let's move on now to Leslie Jordan I
think that we are all still processing
his passing yesterday yeah I I I will
always remember Leslie Jordan he was in
one of the first commercials that I ever
did really he's so brilliant I followed
him uh for so many years yeah I loved
him all of our hearts are broken yeah
and he was so much fun when he hit our
set it's been a collective outpouring of
shock and sadness from his Hollywood
friends and fans and now we're learning
new details about his tragic death
he was alive yeah somebody say are you
still alive Tillman I think he responded
with it yes was he under some kind of
medical no that's all he can say thank
you Leslie's assistant wouldn't
elaborate yesterday on the apparent
medical issue that caused the 67 year
old to collide with a curb and tree
before crashing into this building the
lafd Tells E.T when they found the actor
he was pulseless not breathing and they
tried for more than 40 minutes to
resuscitate him while the coroner will
determine a cause of death the actor has
been candid about his past sobriety
struggles I went to jail five times I
had also had a little Crystal math
problem but we won't go into that if you
can picture a brother boy on crystal
it's got to stop I am really sorry right
I need to show you something
this week Leslie was slated to film his
ninth episode of Fox's call me cat et's
learned Thursday night's broadcast will
now include an in memoriam dedication
co-star Mayim Bialik posted we will be
taking time to grieve while production
is on pause
in the social media Sensations last post
less than 24 hours before the accident
Leslie eerily sang A Hymn about entering
Heaven
people started tuning in and we decided
to make an album just two weeks ago in
his last major interview the Emmy winner
spoke about becoming a country star
after achieving insta fandom during the
pandemic I don't know what happened
people have said to me what's the secret
I have no idea I'm just I'm still in
shock
I'm absolutely in shock
and disbelief
that my little buddy's gone former the
cool kids co-star Vicki Lawrence
revealed to me exclusively she pushed
Leslie on his journey to become a viral
hit back in 2018. I helped him get
started on Instagram he had no idea what
he was doing I didn't have a whole lot
more but I helped him get started and
watch y'all then what would I have to do
well you know um
man woman stuff he
would tell us the greatest stories about
his former life
drugs and alcohol and oh my God they
were saying you look at him and you go
half
way
he was the youngest of us cool kids the
last one you would expect and
just such a bundle of joy I will miss
him Leslie made millions of people happy
and at the end of the day that is the
biggest Legacy that one can leave so God
bless you Leslie and thank you
[Music]